Salut les Terriens Salut les Terriens je
suis très heureux de vous retrouver
notre invité principale ce soir c'est
Christian Mahieu
à la question maillot le bonsoir bonsoir
Pour tous ceux qui se posent la question
vous n'insistez pas au retour de Corbier
du Club Dorothée ni à la première venue
de Chabal sur ce plateau c'est Christian
Mahieu
fondateur et secrétaire fédérale du
syndicat SUD Rail c'est vous le mec
qu'on a envie de tuer les matins de
grève qu'on attend le train pendant 2
secondes
on va en parler alors cette semaine
grève à la poste pas de grève de la SNCF
qu'est-ce qui se passe un moment de
garde on oublie Christian il y a très
peu de grève à la SNCF contrairement à
ce que certains disent moins d'une
journée
et le groupe régiment de fortune
[Musique]
alors Christian Mahieu bonsoir bonsoir
je prononce Mailleux pour que les
téléspectateurs retiennent bien votre
nom car si on voit beaucoup dans les
reportages sur les grèves dans les
journaux télévisés on vous voit rarement
sur les plateaux de télévision dans les
dans les talk shows vous reprocher
d'ailleurs aux autres patrons syndicaux
de d'être présent à la télé souvent non
je pense qu'il y a un mélange des gens à
éviter quoi voilà alors qui êtes-vous
Christian Mailleux donc voilà la
médiation
la médiatisation est en marche alors
vous êtes né le 5 décembre 1957 à Clichy
cette fille s'unique d'une employée de
banque et d'un agent de la RATP
vous avez fait vos études au lycée de
Créteil et en 1973 quand tu as eu les
premières manif contre la loi de Bray
sur la suppression du sursis militaire
vous êtes engagés à ce moment
passer disons c'est ma première c'est
mes premières manifestement sur cette
question et ensuite très rapidement son
antimitarisme d'ailleurs de manière
générale
d'ailleurs après objecteur de conscience
les gendarmes sont arrêtés chez vos
parents non
pas trouvé mais j'ai été effectivement
dans une période où un moment donné je
risque
des centaines de camarades à l'époque
d'ailleurs
SNCF
à l'âge de 19 ans
et à 20 ans la CFDT je vais te rester 18
ans à la CFDT jusqu'au jour où Nicole
notta a signé un accord sur la sécurité
sociale avec Alain Juppé vous le trouver
vendu au grand capital Nicole notta non
je pense qu'elle fait un type de
syndicalisme
vous avez jamais quitté la SNCF non
c'est très attaché à la SNCF bah je suis
attaché à surtout mon boulot
alors aujourd'hui vous êtes agent de
maîtrise administratif c'est bien payé
2000 € par mois en étant aujourd'hui non
plus
SNCF ça fait partie des services publics
où il y a encore un déroulement de
carrière et des acquis collectif qui
fait qu'effectivement on peut avoir
encore des roulement de carrière alors
vous êtes donc à la SNCF depuis novembre
heures qui sont privatisés en
l'occurrence depuis très longtemps
d'ailleurs
alors Sud ça veut pas dire Sud en fait
ça veut dire solidaire unitaire
démocratique voilà alors le principe en
gros c'est que vous vous croyez encore à
la liste des classes quoi c'est ça
l'histoire
du syndicalisme je sais pas jusqu'au
bout de quoi mais jusqu'à le capitalisme
ne s'effondre pas tout seul et dans le
quoi c'est quand même ça ah bah jusqu'au
oui enfin moi
aujourd'hui je suis drive vachement bien
deuxième à la SNCF deuxième à la poste
deuxième à l'Assistance publique c'est
bien quand même à la télé pas trop hein
il s'est dit [ __ ] super il a voulu
s'inscrire mais en fait il a pas donné
suite alors votre gros tube le grand
succès de SUD Rail c'est Saint-Lazare
énorme à la musique a été faite par
Nicolas Sarkozy
l'ennemi public numéro 1 Christian sur
Facebook il y avait un groupe pour
abattre les responsables radicaux de SUD
Rail à Paris Saint-Lazare
vous avez fait tout de suite un slogan
soyons tous des irresponsables
de Carla
alors tout ça effectivement pénalise des
milliers de gens pour des fois des
résultats qui sont pas énormes là par
exemple sur Saint-Lazare vouliez six
postes et j'étais enroulé 3 vous avez eu
trois postes et demi donc ça veut dire
que honnêtement est-ce que ça vaut le
coup d'arrêter une gare pendant 3 jours
pour un demi
une affaire nationale parce que
Sarkozy effectivement à lancer ça
franchement c'est une grève qui avait
rien d'exceptionnel
mais ce qu'on remarque quand on
s'intéresse un peu problème quand même
c'est qu'en France il y a seulement 8 %
des gens qui travaillent qui sont
syndiqués c'est pas énorme non c'est un
vrai problème mais je pense que ça
correspond à deux choses c'est une
certaine inadaptation je pense du
syndicaliste effectivement par rapport à
la situation d'aujourd'hui 2e aspect
quand même c'est justement dans le privé
parce que le taux de syndicalisation est
bien plus faible dans le privé
il y a quand même une répression
syndicale qui existe encore dès qu'on
est délégué du personnel délégué
syndical et cetera dans beaucoup de
boîtes du privé
le libéralisme est en crise mais les
gens ne se ruent pas vers les syndicats
aujourd'hui
faire du 5e
des choses et faire en sorte que ça
change si on a les congés payés si on a
des vacances hebdomadaires c'est grâce
au syndicat tout le monde le sait même
pas sur tout le monde le
quand Thibault dit faut pas tout
attendre des syndicats est-ce que vous
avez pas l'impression d'entendre
j'espère qu'il dit on peut pas tout
attendre de l'État on peut pas tout
attendre du gouvernement moi je pense
qu'on peut effectivement tout attendre
des syndicats suffisent de donner les
moyens et c'est pas simple c'est pas
simple notamment parce qu'il y a pas
assez de syndictions en France
aujourd'hui mais je pense que
effectivement les syndicats enrôles
central à jouer alors sérieusement
est-ce que vous trouvez pas les pauvres
trop dociles par rapport à la situation
de violence que effectivement les
pauvres on pourrait s'attendre
effectivement à peut-être plus
un contexte éducation et cetera qui
habite pas à se
révolterie
finalement je pense qu'il faut le
nécessaire aussi pour que les pauvres
Sarkozy avait dit au moment de la loi
sur le service minimum aujourd'hui en
France quand il y a une grève plus
personne ne s'en rend compte
il a dit d'autres trucs pas vrai
c'est pas vrai mais enfin ça nous amène
quand même à la question que tout le
monde se pose question
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors Christian je suis pas là on est
fin septembre donc à priori il y a pas
de raison qu'il y a pas de train pour
les vacances de Noël maintenant si d'ici
là il y en a qu'on la bonne idée de
d'accélérer la privatisation de la SNCF
ou des choses dans ce genre-là il y aura
des grèves il y aura peut-être des
difficultés
mais les mecs des aéroports et vous
attendent toujours le premier jour des
vacances
tout ce que j'espère c'est qu'avec
toutes ces conneries il est vraiment de
fortune vont pas se mettre en grève bon
alors maintenant retour sur vous
Christian maillot donc avec un quiz
Christian ou le Christ
un grand barbu au cheveux longs les deux
les deux
à la tête d'un mouvement d'illuminé les
deux correctes
vous êtes un peu obsédé quand même là
non non un problème avec l'autorité
les deux les deux
capables de miracle
à la limite ça me rassurer je voudrais
un tampon un truc officiel quoi
un peu en perte de vitesse actuellement
les deux
je dirais le Christ moi il a dit
lève-toi et marche le Christ non les
deux c'est quand il y a pas de train et
pour être sûr de ne rien rater
un pouce bleu